[Musique]
pierre moscovici commissaire européen
aux affaires économiques et financières
est l'invité ce soir d'auditions
publiques bonsoir soir et merci d'être
avec nous d'avoir accepté l'invitation
donc des chaînes parlementaires de lcp
assemblée nationale de public sénat de
la fp et du figaro les deux derniers
médias étant représentée ce soir sur ce
plateau par françois-xavier bourmaud et
baptiste becquart messieurs bonsoir tout
à leur gîte boucher et oriane mancini
seront là pour les chaînes
parlementaires et puis il y aura une
séquence dans une vingtaine de minutes
pierre moscovici avec deux
parlementaires
je voulais présente tout de suite il
s'agit du député et l'air damien abad et
du sénateur communiste
éric bocquet parlons d'abord bien sûr
avec vous dans la première partie de
l'europe aujourd'hui emmanuel macron en
a parlé hier soir en confidences devant
un petit groupe de journalistes
elle a d'abord évoqué bien sûr le grand
débat qui aura des conséquences
profondes sur la marche du pays nous
verrons bien sûr le chef de l'état qui a
évoqué une crise qui touche selon lui à
un mal-être dans nos démocraties
européennes il a cité le break site
la poussée du parti néo nazi en
allemagne il a parlé également de la
situation italienne est ce que
effectivement vous voyez une dimension
européenne dans cette crise que traverse
la france depuis plusieurs mois
maintenant c'est le gilet jaune
chaque pays a ses spécificités on peut
pas dire que j'ai une partout non mais
un malaise et on à la démocratie je
crois qu'il ya dans une démocratie
une menace qui est en train de pointer
une montée des périls qui existe qui se
traduit par la percée de ce qu'on
appelle démocratie libérale c'est à dire
des hommes parce que ce sont des hommes
en général qui arrive aux urnes
normalement par les élections que piquet
ensuite ne veulent pas rendre le pouvoir
et et atteignent les libertés il
touche à la dépense d'injustice il
touche à la liberté des médias
ces cas en pologne c'est le cas on
grille de pays où d'ailleurs l'union
européenne estime que les atteintes à
l'état de droit et il ya cette montée un
peu fébrile partout des populismes je
n'assimile pas forcément les gilet jaune
à ça parce que je pense que dans le
mouvement de gilet jaune ya aussi des
éléments très constructif mais enfin
c'est vrai que derrière tout ça il ya
une marmite qui bouillonne il ya des
malaises mal être dans la société
européenne sans doute le besoin je crois
après la crise de 2008 de traiter enfin
meilleure plus profonde qu'on l'a fait
la question des inégalités
moi ça fait des années et des années que
je ne cesse de le dire on est sorti de
la crise les sorties économiquement la
crise la croissance est là on crée de
l'emploi tant mieux mais il reste des
cicatrices sociale et les cicatrices
sociales doivent être soignés oui
françois xavier
cette menace n'est pas nouvelle on le
sait depuis le proxy que cette montée
des populismes en europe
mais alors qu'est ce que fait l'europe
pour y répondre on a l'impression
qu'elle reste qu'elle reste inactive en
tout cas un peu impuissante face à cette
montée publie ce qu'on constate vous
l'avais dit en gris voire l'italie ou
même en france pour une partie des gilet
jaune apparaît moi je veux pas être
désagréable mais le côté on a
l'impression que l'europe ne fait rien
ça c'est une espèce de ritournelle que
personne ne me lasse et que je
n'apprécie pas du tout je ne rentre pas
à vous parce que pourquoi parce que
d'abord première chose savoir ce que
c'est que l'europe est ce que l'europe
c'est un machin à bruxelles qui
s'appelle la commission européenne une
institution où est-ce que c'est au
contraire un ensemble d'états membres et
j'en veux dire les deux mon capitaine
et c'est pas à bruxelles que ça se passe
ça se passe dans chacune de nos
capitales ce spa dans chacun de nos pays
il faut que chacun balaie devant sa
porte
deuxième chose quand je regarde la
situation de nos économies parce que
c'est mon job comme commissaire aux
affaires économiques je vois que on est
vraiment sorti de la crise que la
croissance est là partout qu'elle est
autour de 2% dans la zone euro
je vois qu'on n'a jamais eu autant de
personnes qui ont un emploi
jamais dans l'histoire même si le taux
de chômage reste trop élevé je vois que
nos finances publiques soient assainies
mais ça c'est aussi lié à une graphie
mais on n'a jamais su créer autant
d'emplois créés on n'a jamais eu autant
d'emplois autant de personnes en emploi
et donc et pas toujours des emplois de
qualité donc il reste un défi c'est le
défi des inégalités et là c'est pas à
l'échelle de l'union européenne qu'on
est mieux outillé pour leur ai dit
répondre ou pour le traiter
c'est aussi celle de nos pays il faut
que chacun retrousse ses manches en
disant en à l'échelle de l'europe nous
ont tous le même mouvement
patrice par ailleurs il ya des choses à
faire au niveau européen je pense
notamment à une chose on devra peut-être
qu'ils aient un budget de la zone euro
pour permettre aux économies la zone
euro de converger entre elles c'est
indispensable
est ce qu elle pas aussi un examen plus
profonde conscience de l'union
européenne à faire c'est à dire que par
exemple sur les gilet jaune ya une
exigence démocratique pas seulement sur
le volet économique et le parlement
européen reste la seule grande
institution qui est élu au suffrage
universel est ce que c'est pas le moment
pour l'europe
al'approche d une élection européenne de
faire une vraie une vraie réforme de ce
point de vue là de démocratiser un peu
plus loin d'une grande mauvaise humeur
mais c'est pas du tout le cas
mais vous avez le droit mais c'est pas
vraiment pas le cas je te découvre tu
vois je me reproche surtout pas
aujourd'hui ce qu'ils sont là mais c'est
parfois si vous voulez une certaine
encore une fois lassitude à combien est
une institution élue nationale au niveau
français il y en a deux et l'assemblée
nationale le sénat et le deuxième degré
imaginez-vous pour l'union européenne
c'est un peu la même chose
le parlement européen a été lu par tous
les citoyens tous les cinq ans et il ya
une forme de senna qu'est ce que c'est
c'est tout simplement le conseil des
ministres de l'union européenne au
deuxième degré c'est un ministre qui
sera présentée au conseil et je veux
insister sur une dimension démocratique
passe donc pour la commission on pense
que la commission c'est une bande de
techno
trois fonctionnaires non plus hein on
laissa dans les cahiers de doléances
aucune forme de contrôle mais j'ai été
ministre pendant sept ans dans mon pays
je suis maintenant commissaire pour
devenir commissaire j'ai dû passer une
audition devant la commission des
affaires économiques et monétaires du
parlement européen
très serré et il ya eu un vote à la fin
est-ce qu'on fait comme ça pour les
ministres chacun de nos pays mais un nul
largement européen doit pouvoir avoir
plus de marge de décision il ne fait pas
les lois aujourd'hui le parlement
européen
peut démettre la commission il investit
qui est déjà arrivé qu'il d'émettre une
commission
il a une marge de manoeuvre beaucoup
plus importante que n'importe quel cas
parlement sur les amendements et il
arrive très souvent tout le temps même
que les amendements soient refusés au
parlement européen on fabrique sa
majorité
on a pas d'un côté des godillots le
doigt sur la couture du pantalon et de
l'autre côté des gens qui sont là
uniquement pour flinguer
c'est beaucoup plus subtil que ça alors
là où je vous rejoins scène je pense
qu'il faut plusieurs améliorations comme
démocratie
1 il faut en effet étendre le droit du
parlement être co législateur dans un
des domaines qui est de mon ressort
qui sont les décisions en matière
fiscale si on veut progresser dans
l'harmonisation fiscale il faut passer
de l'unanimité actuelle 28 états membres
qui doivent être d'accord vote à la
majorité qualifiée et à ce moment là ce
serait le parlement qui légifère
première chose deuxième chose il faut
que ce qu'on appelle l'expansion
candidate c'est à dire les candidats
têtes de liste des grands partis
politiques soit quand même un progrès
démocratiques reconnues par tous et
troisième chose il faut ouvrir les
portes et les fenêtres d'un certain
nombre d'institutions je vais en prendre
une
quel j'appartiens j'appartiens à ce
qu'on appelle leur groupe leur groupe c
les ministres des finances de la zone
euro
et c'est vrai que dans une salle fermée
on prend des décisions extrêmement
lourdes une très grande puissance qui
peuvent engager l'avenir de millions de
citoyens regarder ce qu'on a fait sur la
grèce je n'ai pas de munitions sont
mauvaises en soi mais je dis que le
système doit être contrôlé
démocratiquement et donc il faudrait la
ministre des finances de la zone euro
qu'ils puissent ensuite rendre compte
devant le parlement européen et qui est
votre arrivée au parlement européen
moi je suis vraiment pour tout ça je
suis pour plus de démocratie europe et
ailleurs
vous avez cité les inégalités 1 comme
ferment de cette révolte il ya aussi la
question de l'immigration elle a par
exemple aujourd'hui jacques delors dit
qu' on ne peut pas laisser ce dossier de
l'immigration très sensible uniquement
entre les mains des partis anti
européens est ce que là il faut que
l'europe fasse un examen de conscience
sur cette question les questions
migratoires
encore une fois l'europe c'est la
commission européenne son institution
centrale qui est les etam en est de ce
point de vue là je pense que la
commission
fait ce qu'elle peut elle fait ce
qu'elle peut elle essaie de trouver une
politique qui soit à la fois fidèle à ce
que notre tradition humaniste une europe
qui est pas humaniste pour moi ça vaut
pas la peine
si l'europe n'est pas humaniste il faut
fermer la boutique et cette tradition
humaniste je veux dire que on accueille
ceux dont la vie est en danger ou dans
les opinions sont menacés moi qui vous
parle quand je suis né mon père était
encore réfugiés apatrides
il est venu en france en 47 comme
réfugiés je suis très attaché à ce droit
là je pense qu'on doit vraiment avoir
une société ouverte et dans le même
mouvement il ya aussi tout à fait
fondamental de sécuriser nos frontières
d'avoir une politique commune d'asile
d'être capable de renforcer la sécurité
des frontières avec d'un corps de gardes
frontières et de garde-côtes et aussi
d'avoir de la solidarité envers les pays
dits de première ligne
l'italie et la grèce dans les années
précédentes la commission s'efforce de
proposer cette démarche qui est à la
fois équilibré et global les états
membres pour l'instant ont un peu de mal
à s'accorder et je crois en effet que
jacques delors a raison il faut élever
le niveau il faut être capable de
proposer une politique qui soit à la
fois d'envergure qui soit complète qui
soit aussi très équilibré et qui ne
tourne pas le dos de notre moi je suis
pas pour ouvrir michel rocard parlait
vous savez cette fameuse phrase nous ne
devons pas apporter toute la misère du
monde
il ajouté j'aime beaucoup notre part de
près notre part c'est dans libération ce
week-end il ya un an à peine de trente
écrivains qui appelait à sauver la
maison europe qui serait en feu et ils
disent notamment une autre génération a
commis une erreur celle de croire que
l'unité du continent se fera d'elle-même
sans volonté ni effort est ce que
votre génération a commis une erreur on
a tous commis énormément d'erreurs j'ai
été moi-même pendant 20 ans
parlementaire j'ai été ministre pendant
sept ans dans ce pays
je me sens comptable jédir comme les
responsables politiques de
l'insatisfaction nos concitoyens si nous
étions en train de dire nous avons tout
bien fait vous ne comprenez pas je pense
qu'on serait complètement à côté de la
plaque c'est pour ça que je pense qu'on
ait fait le grand débat on avait apporté
ses limites est utile je crois aussi
qu'il faut qu'il en sorte quelque chose
et je souhaiterais que beaucoup de gens
y participer y compris d'ailleurs que le
gilet jaune
il participe parce que au fond le gilet
jaune j'ai dit tout à l'heure il ya du
bon dans le mouvement
ils ont exprimé un triple ras-le-bol ils
ont exprimé un ras-le-bol fiscale j'en
avais parlé il ya très longtemps et dès
parce que je sentais qu'il veut c'est le
mouvement déjà ils ont exprimé un ras le
bol des inégalités il faut que chacun
puisse contribuer à hauteur de ses
propres ressources
ils ont exprimé un ras bol de
l'invisibilité je ne suis pas représenté
alors à côté de ça il ya du complète
isme il y à de l'antisémitisme
il ya eu trois droites il ya la violence
il faut pas être naïf mais au fond le
mouvement d'une certaine façon et n'a
gagné puisqu'il a provoqué ce grand
débat alors il faut aller dans le grand
débat et à aider la vie in an bien sûr
ce résultat mais je pense qu'il faut
jouer ce jeu là et que pour les
politiques que nous sommes j'en suis
toujours au même si je me sens très très
conservateur donc pour vous l'idée de
convois émergé en ce moment deux listes
gilet jaune pour les landes les
élections européennes est une bonne idée
c'est pas du tout ce que j'ai dit je
parle de participer à un grand débat
citoyen quel est votre avis sur une
liste gilet jaune aux européennes
honnêtement c'est la question
je pense qu'ils auront du mal à voir une
seule ni subventionnera plusieurs que
nous voulons est très composite et qu'il
risque d'une certaine façon avec une
addition de petits scores de ne pas
capitaliser sur le grand soutien ils ont
eu
moi j'aime avait été pour franck largé
conseiller technique je décourage
je ne suis pas en train de les applaudir
ni de les blâmer carey
aucun quel con parce que je ne serai pas
candidate que c'est un mauvais calcul
pour un ange je pense moi que le premier
débouché
c'est ce débat et qu'il faut jouer le
jeu de ce débat essayer d'obtenir des
résultats qui soient importants qui
change la donne à la fois la donne
économique et social mme sylla jeunes
démocratique du pays
et c'est un succès plus important que
parce que vous savez les élections
européennes on parle d'europe et donc
bon gilet jaune il doit avoir une
formule à proposer pour l'europe
jusqu'à présent on a peu parlé d'europe
de la maison de l'europe qui est en fait
c'est notamment justement les mauvaises
relations aussi entre certains états
membres très important emmanuel macron
doit rencontrer demain à chypre je vous
ai pas compter le premier ministre
il ya eu des échanges très tendu entre
les deux nations ces derniers temps est
ce que vous pensez qu à ce stade une
conciliation impossible puisque matteo
salvini a quand même parlé d'un très
mauvais président français emmanuel
macron a rétorqué que la nation
italienne mérite et des dirigeants à la
hauteur est ce que vous pensez qu'une
conciliation est possible ces bolides
j'abhorre ya pas besoin d'un tiers pour
se concilier ya juste besoin d'avoir un
peu de conscience historique
quand je vois ce qui nous lie à l'italie
dans la culture dans la géographie dans
l'économie dans la politique dans notre
histoire commune
quand je vois que nous sommes tous les
deux des pays fondateurs de l'union
européenne tous les deux des pays
membres du g7 des pays membres du g20
quand je vois que sur les grands sujets
économiques
de manière générale la france et
l'italie sont dans le même camp celui du
refus de l'austérité ou une certaine
pensée ando libéral je me dis que cette
confrontation qui dû essentiellement
motifs de politique interne est juste
absurde qu'on devrait les faces et d'un
trait de plume qu'on devrait être
conscient que au delà de la politique de
tous les jours où des campagnes
électorales
il ya quand même l'histoire cette
histoire c'est que la france et l'italie
ensemble c'est bien quelque chose donc
je me tourne vers les responsables
italiens que monsieur salvini se
comporte non pas comme un chef de parti
mais comme un vice premier ministre dan
chose pour me suis dit maillot monsieur
compter que j'ai rencontrés encore la
semaine dernière est un homme qui est un
ogre constructif et donc il faut qu'on
retrouve la seule relation possible
entre la france l'italie c'est l'amitié
c'est une amitié profonde et c'est une
convergence de vues le reste c'est de la
tactique mal venu parce que le président
français était imprudent
quand il a traité un peu les dirigeants
des partis des pays et nationalistes
possible ça m'est arrivé aussi je les ai
invités de populiste moi je combats tout
ce que porte monsieur salvini monsieur
selvini qui est il vous diriez que c'est
aussi un être aussi ne sache pas
utiliser mon là mais c'était avec c'est
tellement c'est un leader me parlez pas
de monsieur salvini en particulier c'est
un c'est un leader d'extrême droite qui
a déjà fait des apparitions communes
avec madame le pen qui refera un meeting
avec elle qui porte une volonté claire
de détruire l'union européenne telle
qu'elle est et donc du point de vue
politique dans le débat politique
on peut se dire quand on est un pro
européen on doit être en confrontation
avec lui ça n'empêche que il faut aussi
être capable de dépasser cela dans les
relations d'état à état
je n'ai rien contre monsieur selvini le
vice premier ministre je respecte sa
légitimité
et quand j'ai passé avec la commission
un accord budgétaire avec l'italie
c'est avec toujours le même souci c'est
que la confrontation entre nous était
absurde c'est pas parce qu'on se trouve
pas sympathique sur le plan politique
qu'on doit pas travailler ensemble dans
les fonctions qui sont les nôtres c'est
même très important françois-xavier vous
pas vous parler des relations
historiques entre la france et l'italie
aussi un autre pays que des relations
historiques et lointaine est longue avec
l'ensemble des pays européens c'est la
grande bretagne qui a pourtant choisi le
bric site est ce que vous redoutez quand
on regarde ce qu'ils vont en angleterre
même ce qui mène la reine d'angleterre a
appelé les anglais à s'entendre est ce
que vous redoutez que le break site des
bouches au final sur une accroissement
des tensions entre la grande bretagne et
le continent
non je crois pas des tensions mais je
pense beaucoup plus à des lois gnement
qui peut être regrettable savez c'est
pas nous qui avons demandé le break 6 et
des britanniques qu'ils ont décidé donc
celle de fourrure dans les négociations
dans la corde
non parce que encore une fois bruxelles
c'est les vingt-sept et les 27 ont été
extrêmement unie et jaune et raison de
le faire pourquoi parce que de la même
façon que les britanniques défendent
elles leurs intérêts leurs intérêts ils
ont cherché à avoir un peu le beurre et
l'argent du beurre
c'est à dire
l'avantagé de rester dedans et les
avantages de sortir nous nous avons
défendu de nos intérêts qui était que le
marché unique européen avec les
principes les libertés qu'il guide
devaient être défendus et c'est très
compliqué parce que on trouver une
troisième voie n'illustre britannique
tony blair qui a cherché cg mais très
simple donc pour pour en venir ou sur là
où nous sommes
est ce que le drame était évitable oui
oui mais faut encore s'entendre sur ce
que c'est le drame
ce sera un odile voilà il ya deux choses
qu'on sait maintenant des votes du
parlement britannique
première chose le parlement britannique
à ce stade ne veut pas de cet accord
on peut le regretter parce que je pense
que c'est sans doute le meilleur
possible dans la situation mais ça c'est
une première certitude deuxième
certitude le barcamp britannique ne veut
pas non plus d'un new deal sans quoi le
lendemain il aurait signifié son congé à
madame est donc on sait ce qu'ils ne
veulent pas de ce deal
ils veulent pas d'un odile donc il faut
maintenant qu'ils parlent qu'ils mettent
leurs options sur la table y aura encore
des vôtres demain et qu'il dise non pas
ceux qui ne veulent pas mais ce qu'ils
veulent une fois qu'ils auront dit ce
qu'ils veulent la porte de bruxelles
sera ouvert et aehi à toute une série
d'options qui sont possibles à koné ça
peut être un deuxième référendum ça peut
être des élections ça peut être une
extension mais c'est pas à bruxelles
pour le coup que se séparer sonel s'est
fait sur quelle solution je n'ai aucun
j'allais dire résister à un nouveau
référendum en premier je n'ai aucune
préférence exprimée
pourquoi pour deux raisons la première
c'est parce que c'est pas à bruxelles
que ça se décide pour le goût est à
londres
et c'est aux britanniques de dire ce
qu'ils veulent ensuite la porte union
européenne je répète est ouverte pour
discuter dialoguer bordel et deuxième
chose c'est parce que je prends dans
l'hypothèse du référendum
je sais que les pro européens
britanniques le chouette je parle tony
blair rencontrait encore la semaine
dernière notamment milité ardemment pour
ça mais c'est à eux de le décider
il nous faut sur leur demander quoi on
non on a vous savez dans le passé il est
arrivé que l'union européenne donne le
sentiment de faire pression sur un pays
pour qui un nouveau vote
l'exemple danemark ou l'irlande avec la
grande-bretagne et c'était pas forcément
ce qu'on a fait plus heureux il faut
absolument procéder différemment s'il ya
deuxième référendum c'est qu'ils doivent
le décider qui nous devons nous y par
rapport à le plus à craindre d'un lot
dire est ce que c'est la grande bretagne
où est-ce que c'est nous européens nous
français particulièrement pour vous pour
moi c'est très clair c'est mauvais pour
tout le monde mais c'est beaucoup plus
mauvaise pour la grande bretagne qui ont
leaké sur l'union européenne aux
trajectoires sur la grande bretagne ont
demandé que les marchés financiers
n'exprime pas de crainte
je pense que les marchés financiers pour
l'instant pense qu'il n'y aura pas de
new deal vous savez quand je regarde les
prévisions économiques toutes disent
qu'un odile je traduirai instantanément
par une récession une récession forte en
grande bretagne pour la france il y aura
sans doute une c'est une menace sur la
croissance mais qui n'est pas très
importante et essayer autre chose c'est
qu'il faut quand même regarder ce qui se
passe moi je vois des entreprises
britanniques y compris vous parlez du
secteur de la finance qui s'implante à
paris ou à francfort
le mouvement ne va pas vers londres il
va plutôt vers la zone euro et donc je
pense que les britanniques la devrait
réaliser que ce proxy est une très
mauvaise affaire pour dans la série des
alarmes justement plus grand de cet
après midi plusieurs grandes chaînes de
supermarchés et de fast food ont prévenu
les députés britanniques en gros il y
aurait moins de nourriture dans les
rayons de produits dans les rayons vous
qui en connaissait un rayon justement en
économie est ce que c'est quelque chose
qui me semble crédible ou plutôt de
l'ordre un peu de la pression de bonne
guerre dans ces temps là pour ce qui se
passe dans les rayons ne sais pas mais
je vous prendre un autre exemple ce
qu'on appelle se placent chaîne chaîne
de fabrication
si vous prenez la manière dont se
fabriquer les airbus 6-1 odile il faudra
sans doute que
la partie airbus du continent prévoit
des solutions de substitution
parce que je prends j'étais à hambourg
quelque temps j'ai vu la fabrication de
l'airbus a320 et une partie des ailes
qui vient de londres avec un odile ça
veut dire qu'il faudra qu'un jour on
peut pas attendre ça et donc si vous ne
se sera pas sans conséquences sur les
exportations sur la consommation sur
l'investissement donc sur la vie
économique de tout le royaume uni
peut-être les scies à chaîne de
supermarché ça je suis pas capable de le
dire mais la supply chain la chaîne
d'approvisionnement sera durement
touchée oui et c'est pour ça que le no
deal franchement doit être évité mais là
encore ne voulions pas la balle elle est
encore et viable vous avez dit en tous
les cas est encore est vital est encore
bien là bas pour faire beau britannique
il faut qu'il dise maintenant ce qu'ils
souhaitent les européens
j'en suis persuadé sur tout à fait
disponible pour le dialogue
merci messieurs c'est la fin de la
première partie de l'audition publique
maintenant donc ce avec l'entrée des
deux parlementaires je les ai annoncé le
député a l'air de l'inde a mis à bas
depuis le sénateur communiste d'une
heure éric bocquet
pendant que les deux parlementaires
s'installe une question d'un internaute
du figaro pierre moscovici à propos du
venezuela on n'en a pas parlé puisque
l'union européenne appelle à de
nouvelles élections libres maduro a
quand même rejeté l'impudence et
l'ultimatum européen
vous voyez dans cette prise de position
commune de l'union européenne un symbole
justement de ce que vous disiez tout à
l'heure l'opposition entre les
démocraties libérales et puis les
régimes autoritaires
je vois le rappel de position constante
sur le plan international qui viennent
au soutien des démocraties
quelle que soit l'opinion qu'on a pu
avoir au début sur le chat bise ou se
consuma d'euros aujourd'hui on est en
face d'une dictature incontestablement
qui a volé la totalité des pouvoirs il
est donc très important qu'il y ait de
nouvelles élections que la parole soit
rendue au peuple et quand il est aimé et
qu'un délai soit fixée et c'est la
raison pour laquelle moi j'approuve tout
à fait la proposition d'union européenne
la position d' union européenne qui
n'est pas que la position de bruxelles
pour le coup qui est celle de paris de
madrid de berlin de londres rien selon
qui les européens là sont très unis et
c'est ça dont on a besoin que pensez
vous de jean luc mélenchon qui souhaite
lui que nicholas maduro tienne je pense
que monsieur mélenchon est fasciné par
le chavisme depuis des années qu'il en a
épousé peut-être les chars mais
maintenant toutes les dérives et que ça
n'est pas raisonnable je pense que jean
luc mélenchon devrait se souvenir d'où
il vient de savoir ce que c'est que la
gauche et la gauche n'est pas le soutien
à des dictateurs qui écrase la
démocratie ou qui l'ignorent et donc
franchement et ses positions là me
paraît absurde et plus que de mauvais
goût presque indécente
damien abad éric bocquet bonsoir et
merci d'être là
monsieur ben ok vous intervenez le
premier vous interrogez père moscovici
vous avez plusieurs thèmes certains vous
sont chers d'ailleurs je pense à
l'évasion fiscale
je pense également à la taxation des
gaffes a par exemple alors à vous la
parole
oui bon c'est parce que ici
effectivement je voulais aborder avec
vous ce sujet qui à mon avis devrait
être au coeur de la campagne des
européennes campagne qui les gens
engagés à savoir le problème de
l'évasion fiscale dont vous connaissez
les enjeux pour la france entre 80 et
100 milliards qui manquent chaque année
c'est l'équivalent du déficit annuel
constaté pour l'ensemble des pays de
l'union c'est 1000 milliards d'euros
c'est six fois le budget annuel et union
européenne donc c'est dire qu'il ya un
enjeu central sur cette affaire et j'ai
entendu la semaine hier que vous évoquez
la possibilité d'engager
l'idée de mettre fin à cette règle de
l'unanimité qui est une règle
idéal pour ne pas bouger puisqu'il y
aura toujours un état parmi les 27
enfin des 28 états membres aujourd'hui
pour s'opposer à toute avancée en
matière d'harmonisation de transparence
donc c'est une excellente idée j'ai
envie de vous dire chiche
mais comment allez vous procéder parce
que je crois que pour décider de mettre
fin à cette règle est né d'une idée il
faut aussi l'une des limites et des 28
états membres comment allez vous
procéder et qu'en pense aussi au caire
alors d'abord j'ai un point d'accord
avec vous du chiffre je ne commande pas
je pense que ce sont des chiffres
exagérés mais que les chiffres que les
chiffres sont déjà très considérable je
vais prendre un exemple pour ce qui
concerne la fraude à la tva on sait
qu'elle représente à soi seul 150
milliards d'euros par an dont 50
milliards d'euros pour la tva
transfrontalière ses fans anglais et
c'est un enjeu tout à fait considérable
et il l'a mon point d'accord avec
monsieur bouquet c'est que je pense en
effet que la lutte contre la fraude
fiscale l'évasion fiscale l'optimisation
fiscale agressive et et pour une
fiscalité européenne qui soit plus juste
en la matière ça devrait être un combat
pour les élections européennes et en
proposant de passer de l'une à limiter
la majorité qualifiée j'ai voulu lancer
ce débat pour les élections européennes
non pas pour moi même encore une fois je
suis pas candidat aux élections
européennes mais parce que je pense que
il faut éveiller les auriez dit la
lettre
j'aurais pu vous auriez plumes en face à
notre gg c'est un autre sujet jeu à
éveiller les consciences l'unanimité
nous empêche de produire toute une série
de biens publics
on n'a pas aujourd'hui de taxes sur
l'énergie européenne qui soit la hauteur
qu'on n'a pas de lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique les
transactions financières n'a pas de taxe
sur les transactions financières
j'espère qu'on aura une taxe sur le
numérique je me bats pour ça vous le
savez j'ai fait une proposition et il
n'ya pas d'assiettes commune consolidée
d'impôt sur les sociétés bref on fait
beaucoup en matière de lutte contre la
fraude et l'évasion fiscale beaucoup
j'ai fait voter 14 directive en cinq ans
mais je suis conscient aussi que sur les
grandes réformes structurelles on peut
pas pourquoi parce qu'on est fait il se
trouve toujours un état membre pour
bloquer donc à graslin
ma proposition est un objectif
atteignable je connais trop il est trop
bon connaisseur des choses pour ligne
aséanienne tout de suite j'ai voulu je
sais tout je sais qui aura un pays
deux ou dix qui seront opposés mais j'ai
voulu lancer pour le coup pardon c'est à
la mode le débat j'ai voulu mettre le
pied dans la porte
j'ai voulu dire si vous voulez vraiment
avoir de la convergence fiscale ou
l'harmonisation fiscale
il faut un vote à la majorité qualifiée
et ce n'est pas moi qui me suis exprimé
vous devenez position le suivant caire
c'est une communication de la commission
toute entière
son président m'a soutenu complètement
dans cette démarche et ce que j'espère
c'est qu'il ya beaucoup de forces
politiques très diverses
à l'appui de sa vie comme réponse que
pour lier ça me doit provoquer presque
une limite si vous appelez tous les
peuples européens à vous soutenir je
pense qu'ils vont il en manquera pas un
dans ce combat effectivement légitime
pour y compris notre démocratie
mais vous savez si le parlement européen
tout entier le parlement élu venait à
dire c'est ce que nous voulons ce serait
quand même une sacrée pression sur les
états et c'est la raison pour laquelle
je pense qu'on peut enfin en effet un
enjeu de campagne pour le coup assez
trans partisan alors damien abad c'est à
vous avec un sujet de taxation justement
sur lequel l'union européenne pouvoir
c'est notamment la tva sur les produits
de première nécessité c'est un sujet
qu'on voit aujourd'hui beaucoup débattu
oui je crois que le sujet de la
fiscalité très important la proposition
que vous faites de passer unanimité la
majorité qualifiée doit se discuter
échanger effectivement avec les états
membres
ce qui est sûr c'est qu'il faut pas que
ça aboutisse uniquement à des taxations
supplémentaires vers ap la crise et
gilet jaune
elle est née d'abord d'un mouvement de
ras-le-bol fiscale d'injustice mais
aussi de ras-le-bol fiscale et donc ils
feraient pas ajouter de la taxation la
taxation et donc j'avais première
question effectivement sur le fait
d'utiliser ce levier de la fiscalité non
pas en taxation supplémentaire mais
éventuellement un allègement d'impôt
pour les français et notamment pour les
français qui sont le plus en difficulté
notamment la question de la tva sur les
produits de première nécessité ce
commissaire est ce que c'est possible
est ce que l'union européenne peut
avancer sur ce dossier là est ce que
finalement il faudrait changer les
textes
qu'est ce que vous répondez aux français
au gilet jaune mais pas seulement aux
citoyens qu'ils disent mais voilà une
des propositions qu'on veut mettre sur
la table qu'il abaisse la tva sur les
produits de première nécessité première
chose vous savez monsieur abad que j'ai
été le midi finances français a dénoncé
le premier le ras-le-bol fiscal que j'en
ai payé le prix si je suis aujourd'hui à
bruxelles c'est peut-être aussi
que cela ne met pas forcément plus une
famille politique à laquelle
j'appartiens parce que un coup ça va
deux fois bonjour les dégâts et je ne
souhaitais pas qu'on en rajoute à mais
pour parler plus de votre question
d'aujourd'hui
vous savez que il y a déjà des produits
de première nécessité qui sont un taux
réduit y est je pense au gaz électricité
etc il est tout à fait loisible un pays
de demander que d'autres produits soit
introduit dans la liste des produits
assujettis à la tva à taux réduit la
difficulté et c'est aussi une
proposition que j'ai faite qui n'est pas
passé au conseil du fait de l'unité
c'est que pour ça il faut que la france
par exemple demande
et quel est l'accord des autres ça prend
beaucoup de temps alors que moi ce que
je propose c'est que ce soit les pays
eux-mêmes qu'ils puissent décider que
tel produit est à tour et non avec la
normale n'est pas possible si c'est
possible
en plus de temps à prendre du temps et
au journal par exemple mairie de rihanna
fergie est là il ya quelques minutes
pour dire l'union européenne nous
empêche de baisser la tva en dessous de
5% sur les produits de première
nécessité à l'amp est aussi les réponses
cet automne totalement faux
des fois je le répète si le si un pays
le demande si la france le demande alors
à ce moment là il y aura un examen et au
final ça peut se faire après pensez vous
c'est une bonne mesure si j'allais venir
au fond premièrement je conçois tout à
fait qu'on le demande je pense qu on est
dans une demande de pouvoir d'achat et
qu' il ya des réponses fiscale qui
peuvent être apportées je ne suis
surtout pas pour ajouter de l'impôt à la
peau deuxième chose
après vous savez très bien qu'il faut
quand même que l'évaluer de manière
assez précise parce que la tva est
commun est un très gros rendement et si
vous baissez le taux de tva le reste on
a vous avez des pertes pour les finances
publiques considérables et donc ça veut
dire qu'il faut
d'une façon ou d'une autre compenser ces
signifie notamment qu'on doit travailler
beaucoup sur la dépense publique et puis
dernière chose il faut vraiment
s'assurer vous êtes des élus du peuple
que ça serve à baisser les prix pour le
consommateur final et pas accroître les
marges pour les distributeurs et des
exemples récents ont montré que
il fallait être très vigilant là dessus
mais moi je n'ai aucune antipathie de
principe à ça au contraire monsieur
évoqué oui je voulais quand les gilets
jaunes aussi bien sur les gilets jaunes
oui effectivement ça fait partie des
préoccupations pouvoir d'achat et les
débats en cours par tous a ressurgi
justice fiscale justice sociale la
fiscalité plus progressive les moyens de
mieux vivre tout simplement une vivre
une vie digne donc la tva en fait partie
effectivement c'est la moitié des
ressources du budget de la france celle
qui pénalise le plus la taxe la plus
injuste que vous soyez allocataire du
rsa ou ou milliards d'eur ça n'a pas le
même impact sur votre pouvoir d'achat et
donc c'est une vraie préoccupation
effectivement et je pense qu'il faudrait
avancer fortement sur cette idée là
d'avoir une fiscalité haut niveau la tva
beaucoup plus juste en termes de
fiscalité pour l'ensemble des
consommateurs de ce pays
encore une fois je pense que si une des
conséquences du grand débat était que
cela soit envisagée est demandée on se
prend un peu plus de temps que ça
pouvait décider directement c'est pour
ça que je pense qu'il faut la
subsidiarité en la matière tels que ce
soit les états membres qui décident mais
je pense que la commission européenne
n'aurait aucune raison de s'y opposer
je pense qu'au final ce seraient
acceptés et limiter ça prendrait
peut-être un peu de temps et que la
liste qui aujourd'hui fixé à bruxelles
pourrait être modifié je préférerais
qu'on dit des listes nationales encore
une fois mais derrière ça il faut bien
penser à l'impact sur les recettes bien
penser à l'impact sur les déficits
et quand même se garantir le fait que
c'est le consommateur final
notamment celui qui a la propension à
consommer la plus élevée et qui est en
effet le plus modestes qui ont bien
difficile et c'est cela qu'il faut
rendre du pouvoir d'achat c'est comme ça
que je conçois votre et proportionnée
pour laquelle lt qu'il ya eu la saba
notamment sur la tva par rapport à la
filière cheval et une fille elle savait
très importante en france on a vu le
nombre difficulté on se dit que c'est un
combat qui sera in fine est difficile là
où je vous rejoins c'est qu'il faudrait
appliquer strictement le principe de
subsidiarité et laisser la capacité aux
états-nations de pouvoir gérer cette
politique et économique l'a fait en
réalité je pète technique mais il ya une
liste qui est fixé à bruxelles
aujourd'hui et pour la modifier il c'est
tout un travail technique et
faut que les états membres ensuite
choisi ce mois je souhaite que les états
ont choisi ce qu'en gt misé finances
j'étais confronté à la filière cheval
d'un côté j'étais confronté de l'autre
ou producteurs dibbouk ou la presse en
ligne
moi je pense que c'est des choses qui
doivent se décider non pas à bruxelles
mais à paris après les conséquences
financières de l'apd est retraité et ce
serait beaucoup plus simple si c'était
traité à l'échelle nationale qu'à
l'échelle européenne
j'avais une autre question sur le
commissaire c'est ce qui m'a frappé tout
à l'heure au début de votre propos c'est
finalement le sentiment que rien ne
change que ou un édit vous avez dit oui
les emplois sont de retour tout va bien
dans le meilleur des mondes alors là où
je vous rejoins c'est qu'effectivement
on n'a pas à faire de l'europe le bouc
émissaire de tous les maux en france ça
c'est une certitude mais entre ça et
celles et ceux qui parfois à la
commission ou ailleurs ne veulent rien
changer sur la politique industrielle
sur la politique agricole sur la
politique de recherche et développement
surtout est-ce que vous croyez pas que 1
il ya quand même une fracture
démocratique profonde aussi entre
l'europe et les citoyens européens s
croyez pas que finalement le passage
vous ai dit il faut renforcer le rôle de
co initiateur du parlement j'ai été
député européen je partage la messe
croyez pas que c'est une réponse
insuffisante est ya pas d'autres
éléments de démocratie qu'on doit mettre
en europe pour corriger cela et puis
deuxième point c'est sur l'europe des
territoires qu'on n'a pas évoqué jusqu'à
maintenant est-ce que c'est pas là aussi
un grand jeu de ce débat de la campagne
des élections européennes que de
rapprocher encore davantage l'europe de
ces territoires
le ciel je vous sais trop intelligent
est trop fin pour vraiment pensé tout à
fait ce que vous avez dit tout à l'heure
que j'ai exprimés c'était pas que tout
allait bien tout va bien mme la marquise
j'ai simplement voulu dire ne jetez pas
le bébé avec l'eau du bain
je le dis pour des pro européens dont
vous êtes nous tournons pas contre
l'union européenne ne faisons pas un
bouc émissaire c'est un bouc émissaire
facile
il peut pas répondre et c'est inexact
parce que j'en européenne mais changeons
la changer l'union européenne
l'améliorer j'ai évoqué moi même
quelques éléments démocratique
ça va tout à fait dans le sens de ce que
je souhaite et je redis une chose c'est
que pour moi dans le prochain mandat
lui parlement européen la commission
européenne je serais probablement monde
ni de l'une ni de l'autre
il faudrait qu'à cause des inégalités le
combat contre les inégalités sont qu à
premier et il ya une mesure à laquelle
je crois profondément jeudi d'une d'un
mot c'est un vrai budget de la zone euro
parce qu'aujourd'hui on à l'euro je
pense que c'est une monnaie à laquelle
nos concitoyens sont très attachés dire
tous les partis maintenant le
reconnaissent même le front national où
le rassemblement national a cessé de le
combattre dans son existence
mais je suis conscient aussi que l'euro
c'est la stabilité mais ce n'est pas la
dynamique et ce n'est pas la convergence
et je voudrais qu'il ya budget la zone
euro qui permettent de faire face aux
chocs de stabiliser la zone euro de
développer la compétitivité et ça c'est
une proposition qui est toujours sous la
table là beaucoup de la race et voilà
notre thème avait un mois de campagne
pierre moscovici a dit qu'il avait deux
pro européens en face de lui vous vous
définissez comme pro européen à la mode
à la mode moscovici ou bruxellois ou
européen l'europe des solidarités et des
coopérations mutuellement avantageuse et
une europe de la démocratie parce que
les votre parti ne cesse de taper sur
l'europe sur cette l'europe c'est leur
rupture libérale
je voudrais revenir sur le break site
qu'on a évoqué dans la première partie
et je trouve qu'on est allé un peu vite
ces dernières années depuis que le
référendum ait lieu chez les
britanniques pour analyser les causes de
ce break site on a vite fait de ranger
sa au titre une réaction populiste
parfois que c'est une fois il ya une
partie de cela dans les questions
effectivement n'y a pas que cela
si vous superposer la carte des
situations économique et social du
royaume uni et du vote pour livres pour
quitter l'union européenne ça se
superposent exactement là où vit mal
socialement économiquement on a voulu
sortir cette union européenne
il ya un déficit démocratique terry
parce que ce break site
ce n'est pas un éclair dans un ciel
serein il ya eu des alertes aux peuples
européens qui ont dit non souvenez-vous
2005 référendum en france 55 % des
français ont dit non on veut pas de ce
projet commission européenne
les blés néerlandais quelques jours plus
tard ou eu le même vote non les
irlandais en 2008 ont voté non au traité
de lisbonne
il ya un sujet quand même pourquoi la
commission n'entend jamais ces cris ces
alertes qui ont déjà eu lieu et on a on
n'aime pas les l'europe n'aime pas que
les peuples dit
bien les peuples et licka dit non il
faut l'entendre il ya des raisons
fondamentales il le regrette aujourd'hui
par apparemment mais j'en sais rien a
exprimé ce vote doit être respecté il
est ce qu'il est on est d'accord mais ok
c'est sur le coup nous sommes totalement
en train de respecter ce vote nous le
regrettons tout autant mais je le redis
la porte de l'union européenne apporte
de la commission européenne elle est
ouverte nombre et à l'idée qu'ils
avaient fermé aux indications du peuple
mais d'abord je les marchés financiers
sont pas inquiet vous l'avais dit je
pense qu'effectivement je veux revenir
quand même sur ce que vous disiez sur la
fracture démocratique
moi je réponds oui vous je ne suis pas
membre de votre parti j'aurais plutôt
utilisé le terme de fracture sociale
parce que en l'occurrence la carte dont
vous parlez c'est pas une carte de ceux
qui votent comme ci ou de ceux qui
votent comme ça c'est une carte en effet
de ceux qui s'ouvre par ailleurs il ya
toute une histoire des relations entre
le royaume uni et l'union européenne il
ya des hommes politiques dont aucun
parent tony blair et loire tisné défendu
leurs pagnes les médias il ya un travail
qui n'a pas été fait il ya le fait que
ce pays a toujours été en marge il n'est
pas dans l'euro il n'est pas dans
schengen
il a toujours demandé avoir des retours
budgétaire mais c'est à guantanamo ni
bac madame thatcher c'est donc une
histoire complexe mais là où je vous
rejoins sarr c'est vraiment le fil rouge
pour moi c'est là où il y as in égalité
là où il ya inégalité sociale il y a
populisme d'un côté et de l'autre côté
il y à monter anti européenne ou contre
l'europe
il faut entendre ça ma façon de
l'entendre c'est pas de dire qu'il faut
céder tout c'est de dire qu'il faudra
répondre aux sous jacents et le sous
jacent ce sont les inégalités
je souhaite que des élections
européennes sortent des forces
politiques qui sont capables de se dire
l'europe est un outil de combat contre
les élites et vous parler d'europe
libéral moi vous savez sur l'or ne sont
pas un échec de l'europe libérale de la
construction du graal de l'europe
l'exemple j'entends tout sur l'europe ce
temple que l'europe est ultra libérale
et quand je me tourne vers la
concurrence en gris j'entendais peillon
on dit que c'est une nouvelle union
soviétique que lui
la commission est une super bureaucratie
puissante la vérité c'est que l'europe a
été construite sur un marché monsieur
bancaire oui sa bande à commencer par le
marché avait commencé samedi marché
comme un marché et le marché les gens
supposent aussi des libertés et comme
ils marchent et ça nous a quand même
beaucoup profité c'est ce qui a permis à
nos économies de se développer
nous avons 70 % d'interdépendance entre
nos économies la concurrence vous savez
moi c'est une vieux débat je ne vois pas
pourquoi la concurrence serait faussé
bas libre je ne vois pas dans quelle
économie ça marche mieux comme ça mais
il faut pas non plus travailler de
rochers s'est pas une concurrence loyale
il faut par exemple il faut pas aller
trop loin je pense qu'il faut aussi être
capable maintenant de développer des
politiques industrielles
quant à la directive travailleurs
détachés pour savait qu'elle est en
train d'être revus de manière puissante
de manière à ce que ce soit le principe
du pays de destination c'est à dire
celui où le travailleur arrive qui
s'appliquait pas le principe du pays
d'origine autrement dit qu'on applique
les règles sociales françaises pour un
travailleur qui vient d'ailleurs je
pense c'est un progrès c'est vrai que ça
a pris trop de retard et abattent c'est
vous qui aurez le mot de la fin dans ce
débat oui je voulais poser une question
peut-être un peu plus politique dans le
sens où qu'est ce que vous pensez
aujourd'hui de la politique du président
de la république des annonces qu'il a
faites de 10 milliards d'euros notamment
de mesures pouvoir d'achat est ce que
ces mesures qui ont été bien acceptée à
bruxelles auprès de la commission
européenne en tant que telle delà de ça
ce que vous croyez pas qu'il ya un jeu
dangereux qui est menée actuellement que
de vouloir et créer un système binaire
politiquement en disant il ya d'un côté
les pro européens qui seraient tous
terrier le président la république et de
l'autre les antieuropéens du sort de
frais xive déguisez vous l'avez dit
vous-même vous êtes attaché la diversité
au pluralisme des idées au sein du
parlement européen
c'est qui a d'ailleurs été une force
c'est ce qui permet de créer des
coalitions d'idées qui permet d'avoir
cet élément de stabilité ce n'est pas le
sentiment aujourd'hui que finalement le
président avec française les joue un
petit peu avec le feu sur ces sujets là
je suis un citoyen français je suis
responsable politique français j'ai pas
complètement perdu tout raisonnement
politique mais comme commissaire j'ai un
certain devoir disons de prudence papa
de neutralité mais je réponde de la
façon suivante à votre question
1 sur les dix milliards la commission
européenne a considéré je crois qu'on
peut pas lui reprocher
que dès lors qu'il y avait une urgence
sociale importante une demande de
pouvoir d'achat est dès lors que le
dépassement des 3% étaient temporaires
sur une seule année
nous n'avions pas de remarque
particulière à faire autre que il faudra
quand même qu'en 2020 reviennent en
dessous de 3% et que la ligne dans la
durée en appel réduction des études
alors non on appelle ça juste de
l'appréciation intelligent de nos règles
on l'a fait déjà dans le passé pour
d'autres c'est bloqué d'une certaine si
charles a fait aussitôt rinaldi actif
c'est de revenir en dessous des 3%
ah ben ça le l'objectif doit être de
revenir en dessous des 3% en 2001 parce
que vous savez qu'à une procédure qu'on
appelle la procédure pour déficit
excessif et qu'un pays qui dépasserait
deux années de suite et 3% se retrouve à
un nouveau procédé déficit excessif je
pense que c'est bon pour la france
je pense qu'il faut continuer le
mouvement de réduction de la dette
publique parce que la dette publique
pèse sur les plus jeunes
la deuxième chose moi je ne me prononce
pas pour savoir où sont les
pro-européens les anti européens mais je
sais qu'il y en a et je sais que il ya
plusieurs variétés de pro européen qui a
plusieurs partis pro européens
je sais qu'il ya aussi des anti
européens je sais qu'il ya des forces
populistes d'aujourd'hui qui en effet
attaque la démocratie libérale et
veulent détruire l'europe
je crois que les pro européens quand
même plus en commun qu'ils ne le disent
est ce que pour autant ils doivent se
rassembler dans un seul parti
je me suis déjà exprimé là dessus je
pense que il ya deux questions dans la
section open la première c'est stop ou
encore est ce que vous êtes pour ce que
vous êtes contre elle existe cette
question il ya une deuxième c'est qu'est
ce qu'on fait est là il est tout à fait
logique que les conservateurs les
socialistes des écologistes
les libéraux n'apporte pas même à les
terminer par ce fait de l'université
dans le prouveront pit stop ou encore
d'un mot alors mais c'est bloqué c'est
avant tout souhaité ou encore stop et
encore c'est la question stop ou encore
soit pas encore à quoi alors
alors oui mais autrement sur d'autres
pages avec d'autres objectifs a encore
nos responsables des coopérations
mutuellement encore et beaucoup mieux
d'accord merci beaucoup monsieur d'avoir
participé à cet échange c'est la
troisième partie tout de suite
d'auditions publiques avec nos deux
consoeurs journalistes qui arrive
une question internet en attendant
encore yann signée brigitte boucher
s'installe vont se fermer dame
un téléspectateur qui nous suit sur le
figaro là et se demande à propos de
l'iran est-ce qu'on va vraiment on a
beaucoup parlé jusqu'à présent des
divisions de l'europe de l'impossibilité
de l'europe de se mettre d'accord sur
certains grands principes aux grandes
décisions est ce que l'europe va réussir
à passer outre le boycott imposées par
les états unis pour commercer avec
l'iran manifestement une structure qui a
été envisagée ça coince encore
aujourd'hui on y travaille
il faut aussi à rien c'est pas simple
vous savez pas ce que les les actions
extra territoriale des états unis sont
extraordinairement puissantes
il faut qu'on renforce et ça c'est une
proposition aussi la commission le rôle
international de l'euro il faut qu'on
ait un véhicule monétaire qui soit à la
hauteur de ce qu'elles dollars il faut
aussi qu'on est en effet un véhicule
financier en elle travaille en est
faible face aux états unis non vous
savez le dollar un niveau faible dollars
à une histoire séculaire un euro à 20
ans et en 20 ans le roi largement pris
sa place mais il ya une dimension je
l'évoqué une tout à l'heure qui manquait
qui était celle de la solidarité y en a
une deuxième qui celle du rôle
international la commission fait la
proposition
il faut encore une fois que les états
membres c'est en fait un des
propositions un bar à pâtes tout un
valorial bon faut regarder le
track-record à la fin bach le
track-record oui pour compléter pour
commencer là la question que damien bad
vient de vous poser à l'instant sur les
10 milliards alors vous avez répondu sur
les 10 milliards mais on voit bien en
écoutant le débat en écoutant les
français qu'ils demandent d'autres
mesures pour augmenter leur pouvoir
d'achat mesures qui ne seraient pas
toutes indolore pour les finances
publiques est ce qu'aujourd'hui vous
mettez en garde emmanuel macron edouard
filet vous dites attention à ne pas trop
sortir le chéquier
j'suis pas les mettre en garde ou pas je
crois qu'ils sont très conscientes ce
qu'ils ont à faire ils sont conscients
que
il ya une politique de finances
publiques en france sont conscientes la
france est le seul pays de l'union
européenne de la zone euro aujourd'hui
qui dépasse les 3% et qu'ils ont la
volonté de revenir sur une piste qu'ils
soient plus réalistes dans la durée
après 2020 2009 une année spéciale parce
qu'il y eu deux événements
il ya d'une part les 10 milliards mais
aussi ce qu'on appelle un one off un
événement exceptionnel et qui la
transformation du cic eux en baisse de
charge sociale pérenne qui représente
tout de même 0 9 point de pib ce qui
fait qu'ils la france devrait revenir
nettement de ca de 3 % en 2020 vous
savez du point de vue la commission
européenne mais aussi du point de vue
des intérêts français pour que la dette
publique n'expose pas et les proches de
100% je pense qu'il faut retrouver un
chemin qui soit un chemin continu de
réduction des déficits
vous avez plus inquiet quand même dans
le passé à leurs traits situation était
peut être encore moins graves
non je suis pas inquiet je m'amuse je
suis vigilant je pense qu'il est tout à
fait naturel quand un mouvement de cette
nature se produit que la commission
européenne justement ne disent pas ce
n'est pas le rôle du gendarme
enfin on nous reproche tout fond on nous
reproche parfois d'être trop laxiste et
puis parfois d'être trop dur moi
j'essaie de trouver une troisième voie
pour le coup entre les deux qui est
celle d'une a programmé un projet
intelligent des règles les déficits
budgétaires pouvant atteindre trois et
demi pour cent en 2019 est ce que vous
pensez qu'il est possible en 2020 de le
réduire sous les 3% ça paraît presque
déficit budgétaire l'annoncé de 3,2
c'est un dépassement qui me paraît
raisonnable
pourquoi vous savez les règles qu est ce
qu elle dit je voulais rappeler quand
même un pays ne peut pas passer au
dessus de trois et demi pour cent sur un
an donc le dépassement doit être
inférieur à trois et demi ensuite il
doit se mettre en position de repasser
en dessous de 3%
la deuxième elle sans quoi deux années
de suite au-dessus de 3% là aussi on
appréciait d'une physique massif et donc
je pense que ces chiffres là nous les
échanges ont avec les autorités
françaises vous savez moi je suis en
contact constant et mes équipes avec
celle du président la république du
premier ministre du midi des finances on
a un travail qui est un travail
collectif
je pense que le souci le même partout
c'est à la fois de laisser la france
mener sa politique économique de laisser
la france mener sa politique sociale de
répondre à l'urgence qu'une crise
sociale mais aussi de garder un cap qui
aiment cap commun et ce cap il n'est pas
idiot
les 3 % c'est pas ça c'est pas une règle
arbitraire
qu'est ce que ça veut dire simplement il
faut réduire nos déficits pour la dette
publics réduisent si la dette publique
augmente lorsqu'on la charge de la dette
augmente et chaque euro consacrée au
remboursement du service de la dette est
un euro en moins pour l'éducation l'âge
d'égibilité une fois parvenir des chiens
mais vous savez l'arrivée 3%
c'est un débat totalement français mais
je suis très content de venir en france
dont on passe toujours la question est
ce que vous savez quelle est la moyenne
des déficits dans la zone euro je dois
vous posez pas inférieure à 1%
voilà dans tous les pays de la zone euro
se débat sur les 3 2%
c'est pas seulement c'est pas un tabou
c'est que c'est un souvenir il ya des
groupements politiques dans notre pays
vous avez déjà réagit toujours derrière
cuit à jean luc mélenchon par sur le
lean et zola il y avait un mouvement
politique particulier qui nous disent la
dette n'a finalement pas beaucoup
d'importance c'est pas ça qui détermine
la richesse du pays on entend ça à
gauche aussi
je sais pas comment ça se passe pour
vous mais moi ma famille dans mon fou et
quand je suis endetté je le sens passé
et je sais qu'il y beaucoup de choses
que je ne peux pas faire je sais qu'il
ya des contraintes qui s'exercent sur
moi sur la façon de vivre et donc non la
dette s'appauvrit franchement jean luc
mélenchon il faut quand même qu'ils
remettent un peu
l'église au centre du village quand on
est endetté on est plus pauvres on n'est
pas plus riche et il ya des contraintes
de dette elles valent pour un ménage mal
pour une collectivité
elles valent pas en état il ya déficit a
dérapé au moins 3,2 pour cent et puis à
côté de ça il ya l'objectif de
croissance le budget est basé sur une
croissance d'environ 7% hors les
principaux instituts fmi-banque de
france insee soit un an et demi pour
cent est-ce que du coup le déficit ne
pourrait pas s'aggraver et est-ce que
vous jugez le budget de la france
réaliste avec une croissance d'un
dernier c'est pour ça que j'apprends des
mois sur ça on a on a rendez vous dans
ce qu'on appelle le cas du semestre
européen ont fait des prévisions il y a
les projets de budgets y sont approuvés
ou pas est celui de la france
nous n'avons pas mis les lasers nous
avons dit aussi qu'il y avait des
risques nous les suivons nous en
reparlerons - demain vous nous aurons
moins mais je peux vous annoncer aussi
quelque chose c'est que dans quelques
jours je crois que c'est le 7 février
j'annoncerai les nouvelles prévisions de
croissance pour la zone euro et nous
dirons ce que nous pensons de la
croissance française comme de la
croissance de l'ensemble des pays de la
zone euro à 2 5%
je ne connais pas assez le chiffre ou si
je les connaissais journal a évoqué un
coup de frein sur la croissance dans
l'union européenne qui craint ce qui est
exact vous savez tous les instituts tout
du conte d'organismes internationaux
sont en train de réajuster que leurs
prévisions de croissance le fmi l'a fait
la banque centrale européenne l'a fait
et on objecte contre moi je pense qu'on
est quand même encore sur une croissance
qui robuste mène à des risques plus
importants des risques qui viennent de
l'extérieur notamment le risque
commercial le shutdown américain n'a pas
été une bonne nouvelle pour la
croissance américaine
on appelait la situation des comics
chinoise qu'il faut suivre et puis on a
nos propres risques internes mais
qu'elle a commencé par le break 6 tout
même à qui j'ai dit était un risque plus
important
non non je parle des risques internes à
l'échelle européenne un proche moi pas
de la france la france fait partie de la
zone euro et donc bon c'est vrai que
l'on surveille ses risques de façon
particulière ce n'est pas sans impact
sur la croissance et le fmi par exemple
s'inquiète de l'impact négatif des
protestations en france
est ce que vous partagez le pessimisme
du fmi non je pense que la france est
une économie qui doit être capable de
surmonter cela et qui doit aussi être
capable d'affronter en débat ce qu'il
faut si c'est que ce débat débouche sur
quelque chose et débouche aussi sur j'ai
dit une transformation économique et
social plus puissante
je suis pas en train de survaloriser
vous savez la base et la patte du même
si la jaune
il a déjà été évalué en fin d'année
parce que pour le coup sûr 2010 8e ra
justement on verra sur 2019
mais bon moi ce qui m'intéresse c'est la
durée et dans la durée des fonds
structurels oui mais des réformes
structurelles nouvelles
je pense qu'il faut aussi être capable
dans un pays il faut préparer son futur
la priorité doit être absolument donner
à l'éducation à l'investissement à la
cohésion à l'innovation
c'est ça que
ce attendent des réformes du futur et
puis il ya aussi très important qui est
une politique juste qui soit capable de
recueillir un assentiment fort parce que
quand les français se sont bien alors
est le moteur principal
je suis pas moi aujourd'hui dans la
police française je dis simplement que
ce que j'entends j'ai quand même des
suffisamment longtemps pour ne pas
simplement parce que je pense que les
français émettent une demande d'être
entendu une demande justice et une
demande de faire face au ras-le-bol
fiscale après c'est au gouvernement
sortant soit dans ce débat bien la
justice fiscale la justice sociale mais
sais pas je ne suis pas en train de dire
attention je suis pas un maître d'école
je dis simplement qu'ils à ses attentes
qui se sont très clairement exprimé je
le dis ras-le-bol fisc un drame holding
a littéralement les a invités il ya ces
symboles plus brigitte évoque à
l'instant c'est l'impôt sur la fortune
c'est une demande forte ça vient souvent
en premier dans les revendications sur
les cahiers de doléances est-ce qu'il
faut leur établir selon vous est ce que
voit encore une fois je ne veux pas moi
être soulever le capot dire qu'il ya
telle ou telle mesure ce n'est pas ou
plus mon rôle ou savez je suis un social
démocrate j'ai appartenu à un
gouvernement qui n'a pas supprimé lisf
bon donc voilà simplement je peux
comprendre pourquoi emmanuel macron a
souhaité le faire parce que c'était un
la peau qui n'avait pas que des qualités
et qui crée aussi un salon de distorsion
en revanche je crois qu'il faut entendre
la demande que d'une façon ou d'une
autre il ya plusieurs façons de faire
ceux qui ont des très hauts revenus
soient capables d'apporter une
contribution plus importante
je vous dis simplement qu'il ne faut pas
ignorer que cette demande là existe qu
en effet les inégalités soient réduites
et que chacun contribue à hauteur de ses
facultés
parce que vous savez le consentement à
l'impôt des plus modestes
il peut être touché si l'on sentiment
que eux payent mais que les très riches
ne payent pas et ça ça s'appelle pas
forcément isf
il ya plusieurs façons de le faire je
crois que la demande de justice fiscale
elle existe oui je suis persuadé qu
emmanuel macron le sais et je crois
qu'il entendra on est déjà aujourd'hui
que
110 % de l'impôt sur le revenu est payé
par moins de 10 % des contribuables
pierre moscovici non c'est pas tous ces
chichis soir sur le seul impôt très
progressiste et jamais vous savez les
tranches dont on parle c'est pas
exactement celle que vous moi ou des
gens même très à l'aise père hongrois
l'euro n'est plus remis en cause dans le
constate la par marine le pen
est ce que vous estimez que c'est une
bonne chose ou le fait que la présidente
de l'assemblée nationale ne critique
plus là
la monnaie commune et la rend plus
dangereuse à vos yeux un peu les deux
mais est ce que c'est une bonne chose
oui oui qu'il y ait un consensus en
france sur le fait que l'euro est la
monnaie désormais des européens qu'ils
ont choisi je pense est une excellente
chose marine le pen s'était pardon une
expression un peu vulgaire totalement
vautrer dans son débat face emmanuel
macron surtout sur ce point où sa
proposition était absolument
incompréhensible en sortir par la porte
et je pense que je pense qu'elle a
compris et je peux pas m'en plaindre que
ce combat là était un mauvais combat
pour le rassemblement national
est-ce que ça accroît sa clarté sa
visibilité peut-être ce qui veut dire
aussi que le combat contre l'assemblée
nationale ne saura peut-être plus sur ce
terrain là mais il leur faudra beaucoup
d'autres si je devais combattent madame
le pen je vois encore beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup de motifs de désaccord le fait
qu'il y ait des sujets de consensus
commun dans une société ne doit pas
faire de peine
même quand c'est un parti qu'on le
combat qu'ils m'accordent vous dites que
les gilets jaunes finalement c'était une
cause légitime vous les avez quand même
présenté sous cet angle là tout à
l'heure mais pour l'instant ils ont
gonflé les voiles de marine le pen
j'ai dit qu'il y avait du bon et du
moins bon mais j'ai parlé du bon qu'il
questionnement j'ai parlé de cette
expression démocratique extrêmement
forte c'est parce que je soutiens
populaires faune marine le complotisme
j'ai aussi qu'avec l'antisémitisme j'ai
aussi dit qu'ils avaient de l'ultra
droite ne sont pas des choses qu'on peut
accepter par une société
un mot sur un dossier industriel un
européen la fusion siemens alstom
le français alstom l'allemand siemens
qui veulent fusionner notamment pour
faire face à la concurrence dans le
ferroviaire les états les soutiennent
emmanuel macron guélat merkel mais la
commissaire européenne à la concurrence
à des réticences
est ce que vous êtes pour cette fusion
ou est-ce que vous soutenez la position
de notre collègue
d'abord c'est ma collègue qui
responsable et elle seule nous ont pas
le revenu de ce qu on appelle le collège
des commissaires et il faut être
extrêmement prudent sur ces notions
avancées rapides avant 18 ans venu sauf
que c'est pas maintenant ici jeu
je veux pas présenter des choses comme
le fait qu'elle ait des réticences et
comme le fait de savoir si je la
soutiens au delà de chabal je pense que
l a des exigences des demandes parce que
son rôle à elle c'est d'appliquer les
normes européennes sur la concurrence
comme elles sont alors siemens est à la
mode et les concessions siemens et
alstom
il faut maintenant voir si ces
concessions sont ou pas suffisantes je
vous dire quelle est ma position
moi je suis favorable à ce qu'il est
champion on perd je souhaite que cette
fusion se fasse et puisse se faire et je
lui ai déjà dit et je le redis je pense
que c'est dans l'intérêt de l'europe
dans une économie mondiale où il ya des
gérants continentaux américains ou
chinois que de pouvoir faire ce genre de
choses je crois aussi qu'il est
indispensable que ce soit compatible
avec nos règles de concurrence
je connais bien ma collègue margreth
masta guerre qui est une amie je suis
persuadé qu'elle n'a pas une approche
idéologique du sujet mais d' approche
pragmatique
maintenant elle doit être en train de
peser ces remèdes comme on dit la
décision viendra je pense qu'il sait je
ne pense que je pense qu'il ne sert à
rien de faire des pressions car il faut
faire confiance à marc gales vesta
guerre quand même vous rassure et bruno
le maire même s'il fait des pressions
pas ce soir je suis pas là vous voulez
toujours choix de la psychologie je
rassure la concurrence je pense que ma
collègue m'a gardé stagaires une opinion
qui sera raisonnable et pas idéologique
il faut arrêter soupçonné par vous
demander s'il faut changer ça oui je
pense qu'un jour il faudra songer jamais
simplement comme ça n'est pas changé on
fonctionne sur la base des règles
actuelles il faudra s'adapter dans le
futur à la concurrence mondiale nouvelle
qui net notamment de la montée en
puissance de la chine et sa wii ça
demandera des hackers mais ça fait
partie aussi peut-être des sujets qui
doivent être traités dans la campagne
européenne
en tout cas madame vesta guerre elle ne
peut pas être créative ou improvisées
doit partir des règles c'est son rôle
il faut lui faire confiance elle n'est
pas réticente elle est exigeante elle a
des demandes et ses demandes
il faut voir s'ils dominent une question
technique et politique
est ce qu'il est possible d'organiser un
référendum pour emmanuel macron le jour
des élections européennes c'est à dire
le 26 mai
je n'ai pas d'opinion politique mais sur
le plan technique ça me paraît
absolument faisable oui bien sûr qu'ils
soutiendraient vous aux élections
européennes je vous dirai dans quelques
semaines par contre c'était parce que
j'attends de voir quand même savez c'est
une campagne qui sera plus un sprint une
course de fond j'attends de voir quelles
sont les solutions toujours socialisme
mais mais mais la stratégie du parti
socialiste ou son absence de stratégie
sont tellement criante que j'ai été
amené à prendre pour cette élection
mes distances je ne crois pas clos mais
il est trop hésitant une ni pour ni
contre
j'entends sans arrêt du gloubiboulga
j'ai entendu olivier faure a expliqué
compte ouvert à la fin qui on va
soutenir le président de la commission
pourquoi pas monsieur varoufakis les
bras m'en sont tombés
je pense que dès lors qu'il une
stratégie il n'est pas illogique qu'ils
défendent lui-même mais moi ça n'a pas
moi pour ce qui maintenant il en a une
seconde puisque l'équipe les autres mes
côtés moi par exemple monsieur
varoufakis gelé connus comme les
finances grecques incompétent il a coulé
son pays il l'a mené dans le mur et si
franchement c'est ça qu'on soutient
comme président de la commission
non non non et non non non au ps non
monsieur ben arfa qui snobe lisibilité
pendant votre positionnement pierre
moscovici faisait quand même je suis
proche des manuels macombe d'olivier
fort finalement est ce que je voyais à
soutenir la vie c'est clair après
quelques semaines d'angoissé terre de
succès pas non non non je ne serai pas
sur les marches je ne serai pas candidat
aux élections européennes
voilà c'est clair et net on a bien
compris ce que vous pensez aujourd'hui
du parti socialiste merci pierre
moscovici peut-être qu'on vous recevra
la prochaine fois comme président de la
cour des comptes puisqu'on annonce votre
arrivée peut-être dès le mois de février
vous ne voulez pas confirmé ni infirmé
vous resterez silencieux sur ce dernier
volet va marquer dans cette émission je
suis totalement commissaire européen
j'ai encore plein de boulot à faire
à bientôt merci madame
c'est à tout ça très vite
[Musique]